all right let's see if we can find the
indefinite integral of 1 over 5x squared
minus 30x plus 65 DX pause this video
and see if you can figure it out
alright so this is going to be an
interesting one it'll be a little bit
hairy but we're gonna work through it
together so immediately you might try
multiple integration techniques and be
hitting some walls and what we're going
to do here is actually try to complete
the square in this denominator right
over here and then by completing the
square we're gonna get in the form that
it looks like the derivative of arctan
and if that's a big hint to you once
again pause the video and try to move
forward all right now let's do this
together
so I'm just going to try to simplify
this denominator so that my coefficient
on my x squared term is a 1 and so I can
just factor a 5 out of the denominator
and if I did that then this integral
will become 1/5 times the integral of 1
over so I factored a 5 out of the
denominator so it is x squared minus 6x
plus 13 DX and then as I mentioned I'm
going to complete the square down here
so let me rewrite it so this is equal to
1/5 times the integral from of 1 over
and so x squared minus 6x it's clearly
not a perfect square the way it's
written let me write this plus 13 out
here now what could I add and then I'm
gonna have to subtract if I don't want
to change the value of the denominator
in order to make in order to make this
part right over here a perfect square
well we've done this before you take
half of your coefficient here which is
negative 3 and you square that so you
want to add a 9 here but if you add a 9
then you have to subtract a 9 as well
and so this part is going to be X minus
3 squared and then this part right over
here is going to be equal to a positive
4 and we of course don't want to forget
our DX out here and so let me write it
in this form so this is going to be
equal to 1/5
time's the integral of one over get
myself some space X minus three squared
plus four which could also write as plus
two squared actually let me do it that
way plus two squared DX now many of
y'all might already be say hey this
looks a lot like arctangent but I'm
gonna try to simplify it even more so it
becomes very clear that it looks like
arctangent is going to be involved now
I'm actually going to do some u
substitution in order to do it so the
first thing I'm going to do is let's
factor a or out of the denominator here
so if we do that then this is going to
become one fifth times one fourth which
is going to be one xx times the integral
of one over X minus three squared over
two squared and then this is going to be
a plus one and of course we have our DX
and then we could write this as and I'm
trying to just do every step here a lot
of these you might have been able to do
in your head one over and I'll just
write this as X minus three over two
squared plus one plus one and then DX
and now the u-substitution is pretty
clear I am just going to make the
substitution that U is equal to X minus
three over two or we could even say
that's U is equal to one half X minus
three halves that's just X minus 3 over
2 and D U is going to be equal to 1/2 DX
and so what I can do here is actually
let me start to re-engineer this
integral a little bit so that we see a
1/2 here so if I make this a 1/2 and
then I multiply the outside by 2 so I
divided by 2 multiplied by 2 is one way
to think about it this becomes 1/10 and
so doing my u substitution I get 1/10
that's that one tenth there times the
integral of well I have 1/2
X right over here which is the same
thing as D u so I could put the D U
either in the numerator I could put it
out here and then I have one over this
is U squared u squared plus one now you
might immediately recognize what's the
derivative of arctan of you well that
would be 1 over u squared plus one so
this is going to be equal to one tenth
times the arc tangent of U and of course
we can't forget our big constant C
because taking an indefinite integral
and now we just want to do the reverse
substitution we know that U is equal to
this business right over here so we
deserve a little bit of a drumroll this
is going to be equal to one tenth times
the arc tangent of U well U is just X
minus three over two which could also be
written like this
so arc tan of X minus three over two and
then plus C and we are done